anyway uh besides Fried Chicken what
what else
um I love sweets so I love chocolate
dark I'm a milk chocolate girl but I
love dark chocolate yeah me too
I'm a milk chocolate girl because uh it
was yeah so much creamier yeah yeah it's
more delicious but then like the
sophisticated people how do I run
yeah chocolate's not bad like hot dark
chocolate was like uh like some nut
butter in it but people will judge you
because like the real like if you're a
real chocolate person you're gonna do
dark chocolate because it's like the
more sophisticated complicated flavor
right that's like fake that's like
that's like someone going to I don't
know some restaurant and being like if
you don't order this then you didn't
really go to that place I don't think
that really matters I think it's all
subjective they were like coffee I still
drink instant coffee
do you like instant coffee yeah I don't
like I don't think I've ever had
anything I don't like to admit it
because people say that
because they don't consider instant
coffee real coffee but I'm like it's
it's coffee
and it's like reliable like it's I can
count on it I know the flavor
it's good I know the amount
the aroma like the the the whole point
of call not the whole point but you make
it with hot water yeah with hot water
with hot water hot water I'm just
running around
not that way what are you doing how do
you know I just asked you oh so I should
follow this guy but he's just crouching
well you have to use your Eagle Eye
what's the Eagle Eye thing
so these two you click them down at the
same time
and you got to look around because
you're gonna run out of Eli
how do I I think we lost the animal hold
on
cancel it okay
wait don't do it yet
go back to where that animal was and
then look for the all right
let them look for the Sun
chocolate
what are your favorites
like something naughty though because
you eat very clean I don't think
I use the word naughty
or describing food it makes me
uncomfortable does it it's such a weird
word to use I'm feeling naughty I don't
think I feel naughty
it's not I think that's not that's just
not in my vocabulary this thought yeah
uh is this back is this where it is
I think he likes the view I don't know
oh okay so the animals over there so get
close to it and then just look around
and I'm sure you'll find
I love baking by the way actually baking
yeah yeah cookie so cookies like oatmeal
raisin that's the best cookies won't be
a reason I've got a lot of trouble
yeah I went to war on Twitter over this
is your chocolate chip Grill yeah all
right so I'm doing uh opening reason for
me like warm oatmeal raisin so one of my
nephews really loves oatmeal raisin the
other one loves chocolate chips one of
my my following is that yeah that's a
scent
anyway oatmeal resin cookie like a thick
woman resin cookie thick yeah yeah
the thin ones are like it makes no sense
because it's not what are you getting
like yeah there's not enough like
me it's substance to the cookie good job
just like a warm thick oatmeal raisin
cookie with some milk
it's your jam with with almond milk
actually from almond milk yeah with a
cookie the creamy almond milk or like
yeah real almond milk I don't know what
real almond milk is yeah real but not
not sweet not sweet
unsweetened
looking for the horse
got to take the steer on the horse oh
there it is
nice
this horse is great so what's your
favorite cookie chocolate chip yeah I
love a chocolate chip cookie because
there's so many different ways of making
it I'm sure there's the same thing for
it
no I'm gonna grab it I have to move the
horse okay so I had the option to grab
it so you can make like
cakey chocolate chip cookies sure you
can make like a gooey chocolate chip
cookie you can make a chewy one gooey
gooey chewy gooey
um it depends on what like you can add
molasses you want to crumble or do you
want it to be chewy I don't like cooked
crispy I like chewy yeah good good
boy
drops off there's a you know growing up
in uh
I think it's like in the Soviet Union
they had um
I think there's a kind of cake I don't
know how let's call it English but it's
um
which is an ant hill cake I think is it
like an angel no it's a condensed milk
oh with a bunch of yellow condensed milk
is it yes of course of course I'm Cuban
oh let's check on this other I don't do
Cubans do this kind of thing what do
they use it for you use it for a lot of
different things but desserts desserts
yes you can also yeah you can make a lot
of different things with it it's
delicious yeah it's amazing it's like
very sweet and gooey okay
it's the cake with the I don't know it's
it's called Ant Hill people can look it
up it's great and it was just a source
of happiness because my mom will make it
every year for my birthday so oh that's
delicious
but then you like
as you grow up you realize like oh this
is probably really bad for you
yeah it's not great
and I'm the only one that eats it so
when she makes it it's like all right
the entire cake am I gonna do like this
20 000 calorie Contraption am I really
going to take this on and I do because I
can't do a slice of it no you just keep
going the gods of cake
the damn thing so your mom likes to bake
too
like what is your
favorite thing like a home-cooked meal
you know it's like I don't I think it's
just being with family is the favorite
thing versus like a specific meal
probably like barbecuing like
you know I'll usually Grill I'll make me
like
so just getting together around a grill
and then enjoying the meal with yeah and
then just drink like whiskey vodka yeah
I feel that way about traveling like
people romanticize going to different
places but I think it's really about the
company that you keep
it almost feels like we're having a
conversation but we're actually on a
horse having a conversation it does feel
like no worse
which one of mine which one are you I
think they look the same
look how big that deer is my horse yeah
it's kind of incredible this game just
looks beautiful